let's say we have a hypothetical
reaction where reactant a
turns into products and let's say the
reaction is
zero order with respect to a
if it's zero order with respect to a we
can write that the rate of the reaction
is equal to the rate constant k times
the concentration of
a to the zero power and since any
number to the zero power is equal to one
then the rate of the reaction would just
be equal to the rate constant
k we can also write that the rate of the
reaction
is equal to the negative and the change
in the concentration of
a over the change in time
if we set these two ways of writing the
rate of reaction equal to each other
and we use some calculus including the
concept of integration
we will arrive at the integrated rate
law for a zero
order reaction which says that the
concentration of a
at time t is equal to the negative of
the rate constant k
times the time plus the initial
concentration of a
notice that the integrated rate law is
in the form of y
is equal to mx plus
b which is the equation for a straight
line
so if we graph the concentration of a on
the y-axis
and the time on the x-axis
we will get a straight line if the
reaction is zero
order so if we write concentration of a
on the y-axis and time on the x-axis
the graph will be a straight line and
the slope of that line is equal to the
negative
of the rate constant k so the slope
is equal to negative k and
the y-intercept of that line so right
where
the line intersects with the y-axis
uh this point is the initial
concentration of a
so everything we've talked about assumes
that there's a coefficient of
one in front of the concentration of a
however let's say we have a coefficient
of 2 in front of a
in our balanced equation that means we
need a stoichiometric
coefficient of one-half which
changes the math now instead of getting
negative kt
we would get negative 2 kt
after we integrate which means that the
slope
of the line when we graph the
concentration of a
versus time the slope of the line would
be equal to
negative 2k it's important to note that
textbooks
often just assume the coefficient in
front of a is a 1
which would give the slope as equal to
negative k
however if the coefficient in front of a
is a 2
then technically the slope of the line
should be equal to
negative 2 k as an example of a zero
order reaction let's look at the
decomposition
of ammonia on a hot platinum surface
to form nitrogen gas and hydrogen gas
in our diagram we have four ammonia
molecules on the surface of our platinum
catalyst and then we have another four
that are above the surface of the
catalyst
only the ammonia molecules on the
surface of the catalyst can react and
turn into nitrogen and hydrogen
the ammonia molecules above the surface
can't react
and even if we were to add in some more
ammonia
molecules so let's just add in some more
here
those molecules still can't react and
therefore the rate of the reaction
doesn't change
as we increase the concentration of
ammonia
so we can write that the rate of the
reaction is equal to the rate constant k
times the concentration of ammonia
but since increasing the concentration
of ammonia has no effect on the rate
that's why this is equal that's why this
is raised to the zero power
and therefore we get the rate of the
reaction is just equal to the rate
constant k
normally increasing the concentration of
a reactant
increases the rate of the reaction
however for this reaction since we're
limited by
the surface area of the catalyst if the
catalyst is covered with ammonia
molecules
increasing the concentration of ammonia
molecules will have no effect
on the rate of the reaction and
therefore
this reaction the decomposition of
ammonia on a hot platinum surface
is an example of a zero order reaction